so I've been consistently just always
trying to optimize off function and so
like these shirts are super comfortable
if it gets cold I can button up and I
can roll the sleeves down yeah if it
gets a little warmer I can roll the
sleeves up and keep it buttoned if I can
open it and keep the sleeves rolled or I
can keep it open and roll the sleeves
out so I have four different temperature
settings and I can take it off and with
this I have beater and I've got like
basically Hawaiian shirts and I've got
flannels so it's like when it's summer
I'll switch to Hawaiians and it's winter
and I'll have flannels and I just have
Peter as the base I literally have all
of the colors of the shirt now